when it comes to doughnuts I don't care
if I'm betraying my country I grew up
with Timmerman's Canadian it's point of
pride for us the morons I think is the
worst thing I am partial to Dunkin donut
I don't get this Dunkin Donuts hype I
didn't get doughnuts it's gonna be
better
I think Tim Hortons is far superior I
don't like Dunkin Donuts I have low
expectations for both these are the
original glazed doughnut pretty good
pretty light not very fluffy I'm more of
a mushy doughnut man it seems like more
of a bagel than a doughnut enjoy
Dunkin Donuts yeah what thought was
gonna be that to Tim Hortons this is
gross should be better in Canada whoa
yeah this one doesn't really have a
flavor
I hope this one's better I like that got
a pretty rich cracker vibe about it
I would rather ate this one for
breakfast Dunkin Donuts again yes I do
not run on Dunkin stop right now
oh man these are the choco doughnut
holes Dunkin Donuts calls them munchkins
and Tim Hortons called them Timbits the
classic war Timbits versus the Munchkins
they look almost identical oh yeah I can
eat that all goddamn day
not super flavorful kind of bland that
one tastes salty I like this one better
damn it oh okay
I have to get out here that's just sorry
I can't [ __ ] Wow
these are the non decaf original blend
coffees so this is kind of scary for me
because I've been talking crap about Tim
Hortons coffee I don't normally have
coffee after the morning so either way
anyone want a party tonight
smells like absolutely nothing it's
coffee somehow it tastes racist this
one's much better it has like a richness
to it
I was really mild it's like when do you
ever get a cup of coffee in your life it
tastes nice but weak what's so hot that
one did taste better though
you're both kind of terrible this one
tastes more like a cardboard box this
one tastes more like like one of those
Arrowhead bottles it's been left in the
Sun I have to choose one I'm gonna
choose this one okay all right you came
back in the fourth quarter to win me
over to Morton's I guess I've lived in
America for a long time you got some
good freaking coffee though like this
just legit I can notice you're doing a
good job you dish it like open more
stores in LA Tim Hortons all the way you
know we can't go around just hating on
doughnuts because of national
affiliation and whatnot sometimes you
have to like try it and maybe it'll
surprise yourself